alors c'est très sain on joue pas la
honte des dix fugitifs et maintenant on
doit faire un gage le premier gage c'est
très simple c'est tout de suite
ap nicolas de tavernost le patron de m6
ou non c'est bien sûr une piste que tu
crois qu'il va répondre oui bah bien sûr
tavernost oui je ne trompe pas les
rentes et si non non pas du tout s'il
regarde tu crois qu'ils regardent ces
huit studios concurrents
c'est toujours dégage par rapport à vos
rapports avec un chien donc ce sera un
penny collatéraux nomme patron de m6 et
lui dire je suis ton kitutu et aboyer
n'a rien à voir
moi ça me va très bien ici les voix ne
sont pas pipé les dés attend qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire par là michaël youn
a là parce que une fois je suis venu
j'ai fait neuf fois loin alors tu tires
en première quand d'accord sur les
chiffres pairs est le plus petit chiffre
pair attention toi tu es souris mais
sauvé comme ça on a toujours envie à
d'autres nous n'est moi les règles et
celui qui a le plus petit chiffres qui
viennent n'a pas donné sa internat
j'avais entendu c'est parti assez faible
à tapas nicolas tavernost à l'essai pour
toi alors c'est le alors c'est le grand
écart
oui les dirigent la moitié de la france
mais alors lui là le gars qui s'appelle
il dirige la moitié de la france et je
dois l'appeler dur je suis ton ptit
toutou et à bouaye îles tuvalu laissé un
message puisqu'il va paraît pas mais
pour la prière sans colle à nicolas tard
jobbik est magnifique très très bon il
ya ces gens là doivent complètement
oui non si lui dis lui que c'est
stéphane plaza qui a besoin de pognon
c'est pas les ménages à faire stéphane
plaza faire un oignon que la terre
annoncé le patron des titres grand
patron du groupe il appelle vraiment
indique va dire je suis ta petite
chienne a brillé tout est envoyé à fait
comme il pas temps alors allo nicolas
[Musique]
il n'est pas accessible aux abois quand
même c'était cyril hanouna en fait ça va
ça va ils vont très bien
bah ouais parce qu'en fait c'est là on
est et on était en direct en fait
surtout pas mon poste et c'était pour
changer de chaîne et transmettre un
petit message à nicolas je dirais c'est
dire si c'est sur m6 je serai ton ptit
toutou dicko ouaf ouaf
[Rires]
oui
[Applaudissements]
emportez patron de m6 quelqu'un qui
répare et l'a percutée par un ter
maintenant tu vas répondre pour moi
d'accord pour toi ok ok attention
attention les fellahs celui qui fait le
plus petit nombre
jeudi le plus petit nombre doit manger
des croquettes pour chien un homme des
céréales au boss elles sont là que des
frais de battance à ces partis genevois
allemand c'est toi qui attirent bon
c'est pas tous les soirs comme ça 23
c'est pas bon ce 23 c'est super va le
faire pendant à droite et soit et c'est
cela aussi c'est super de trêve il a
bossé dans un casino suzy33 et or est
encore pour toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai craqué depuis ça baigne pas c'est
les croquettes pour chien leurs assurés
sont périmés ou non là je vais finir
égérie de la spa moi c'est bon c'est bon
baba
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va en effet les cartes
attention les cartes je passe une super
attribuer là où vous en êtes sans
marcher sur quelques têtes les crocs tu
descends prêché dans cette technique
image associant la météo ou le bracelet
de chiottes alors il faut faire qui fait
la fête à son maître qui rentre ah ouais
d'accord donc c'est jean michel qui va
rentrer mais voilà hockey depuis le tir
on l'avait eu un échange de coupes
attention c'est parti parce que tu me la
joues encore sur les crochets à toi tu
vois ce que je dois battre aller chez
vous la mélasse et le 1 ou c'est le
alors eh tu es tu dis moi je suis un
tricheur tu choisiras car non il a
choisi non non bon j'avoue y est c'est
pas 4 4
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aulas
les ja cola de faire la iii laisse le
gars c't'un s'arrête de manger donc
rassurez vous ce n'est pas moi la vraie
nourriture les pma tous est malade et le
truc qu'on boit c'est quand tu bosses ah
ben je sais pas mais c'est mort ça passe
pour le goutte à g et la connerie tu
sais
alors attention c'est parti
je suis fou lie à trois boules et à
trois boules celui qui peuvent la plus
petite boule il ya la boule noire celui
qui paye sa boule noire à perdre
d'accord
c'est gbagbo n'ont pas là c'est pas ici
ouf donc ils avaient ils avaient plus de
chances que vous forcément que nos deux
noms n'avaient qu'une chance sur deux
maintenant c'est du hasard au milieu
coule perdre tu la sens la boule elles
seules elles sont pas toutes les deux de
la même texture leblanc général est plus
lisse à mon avis mon unique et bah oui
parce qu'ils l'ont ils ont pensé quoi
ton nom
[Applaudissements]
certes ils ont pas que les blancs de
penser moi et on le sent non aujourd'hui
j'ai c'est le gage souviens pas mais tu
as été sage au plus tôt c'est qui le
bébé
[Applaudissements]
les américains monde est fatigué à
suivre attention ça l'a vraiment vu que
ben jelloun et du plâtre c'est vachement
bon c'est super bon c'est ce qu'a aller
attendu de titouan et là ça je peux pas
alors là on a une avant première
celui qui perd de faire lors du rappel
aux petites chutes
c'est là tu le mets l'arabe a laissé
partir il veut plus qui perd gagne
cette émission est complètement folle
attention syrie que ces partis tu tiens
en premier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et toi tu tires tu écartes tout seul toi
tu te mets indiens chez ma mère je suis
cyril soit un peu par un vendeur je puis
dire quand
bon j'adore c'est ce que j'attendais
depuis le début les changistes mon salon
où bernard navet rappel va bien on était
[Applaudissements]
dans les relais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop tôt
o o
[Applaudissements]
alors la production m'a demandé de venir
te remplace petite semaine parce que
peut-être on n'a pas tiré en ce moment
feuillatte ou se jeter